so we have a polynomial right over here
we have a function P of X defined by
this polynomial it's clearly a seventh
degree polynomial and what I want to do
is think about what are the possible
number of real roots for this polynomial
right over here so what are the possible
number of real roots for example could
you have nine real roots and so I
encourage you to pause this video and
think about what are all the possible
number of real roots so I'm assuming
you've given a go at it so the
fundamental theorem of algebra tells us
that we are definitely going to have
seven seven roots some of which could be
actually real so we're definitely not
going to have eight or nine or ten real
roots at most we're going to have seven
real roots so possible number of real
roots so possible let me write this down
possible number of real real roots well
seven is a possibility this when if you
graph this out it could potentially
intersect the x-axis seven times now
would it be possible to have six real
roots is six real roots a possibility is
this a possibility well let's think
about what that would imply about the
non-real complex roots if you have six
real if you have six relax let's let's
do it this way let's let's let's let me
write it this way so real roots real and
then non real non-real complex the
reason why I'm not just saying complex
is because real real numbers are a
subset of complex numbers but this is
being clear that you're talking about
complex numbers that are not real so you
could have you could have seven real
roots and then you would have no non
real roots and so this is absolutely
possible now could you have six real
roots in which case that would imply
that you have one non real root well no
you can't have this because the non-real
complex roots come in pairs
conjugate pairs so you're always going
to have an even number of non-real
complex roots you can't just have one
so let's rule that out now what about
what about having five real roots that
means that you would have two non-real
complex adding up to seven and that of
course is possible because now you have
a pair here so I think you're starting
to see a pattern essentially you can
have an odd number of real roots up to
and including seven so for example this
is possible and I could just keep going
I could have let's see four and three
this is not possible because I have an
odd number here you're going to have to
have an even number of non-real complex
roots so rule that out
but then if we go to three and four this
is absolutely possible you have two
pairs of non-real complex roots and then
we could go to two and five once again
this is an odd number does these come in
pairs so this isn't possible and then
you could go to one real and six non
real completely possible this is an even
number and then finally we could
consider having zero real and seven
non-real complex and that's not possible
because these are always going to come
in pair so you're always going to have
an even number here
so the possible number of real roots you
could have seven real roots five real
roots three real roots or one real root
for this seventh degree polynomial